another Islamic terror attack in New
York plus the Democrats and President
Trump respond and Civil War controversy
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show terrific terror attack yesterday in
New York City an Islamic terrorist runs
a truck into a bike path and injures 21
people kills at least eight of them
there I think everyone else is is
seriously wounded but but none in danger
of death worst terror attack in the
United States since last month when we
had at least a mass shooting that was
not necessarily a terror attack this is
the worst terror attack in the United
States for at least several months and
there's a lot to say about it also about
what we could do to stop terror attacks
like this if anything and I have a bit
of a more skeptical take than I think a
lot of conservative commentators do
today but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at blinds.com
so this is one part of your house that
sort of seems irrelevant until you look
around you realize how ugly your blinds
are they've been there for 20 years
you've updated every other part of your
house but you just left those window
coverings on there and they look
terrible well that's where blinds calm
comes in that's why we've used blinds
calm at my house instead of going to the
blind store and having to pick them out
and buy them and and have the person
come up new house and measure them
blinds.com makes it really easy if
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start you get a free online
design consultation of blinds calm you
send them pictures of your house they
send back custom recommendations from a
professional from what will work with
your color scheme furniture in specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure that the materials that
you're looking at work well in your home
and this is the best part if you miss
measure or accidentally pick the wrong
color
if you're the one who screws up blinds
calm makes it right for free they've
really made it easy for you so there is
no excuse to have those ugly blinds
anymore for a limited time get 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Bennigan's blinds comm promo
code ben blinds.com promo code bed and
get 20% off everything this is faux wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more blinds calm promo code Ben rules
and restrictions do apply make your
house look a thousand times better with
with a relatively inexpensive upgrade
lens comm check it out today okay so
when the attack itself was it was
horrendous here is what we know about
the suspect the New York terror attack
suspects name is
fool Oh hubby I want to pronounce this
correctly but I'm not going to Robbie
Buhl a say pop and he is a Muslim
he did this in the name of Isis
according to John Miller the NYPD Deputy
Commissioner for intelligence and
counterterrorism sigh - planning the
attack for a number of weeks according
to Miller and appeared to have followed
Isis instructions as to how to carry out
such attacks as soon as a truck ran into
a bunch of people he had to figure that
this was an Islamic terror attacks
simply because that's been the mode of
operation for his been modus operandi
for Isis for years now they started it
in Jerusalem they carried it over into
Nice France they did it the Berlin
Christmas market they've done it in
London so ramming trucks into groups of
civilians has been a Isis staple for a
while now he said that a handwritten
note in Arabic founder of the scene had
both symbols and words but the gist was
that the Islamic state would endure
forever this of course is not true since
the Islamic state no longer really even
indoors so this is the deadliest terror
attack in New York City since 9/11 in
the guy's 29 and he plowed into
bicyclists and pedestrians just blocks
away from the World Trade Center on
Tuesday afternoon here's some video of
the aftermath corner you see feet
bicyclists sound young terrorist attack
I'm not sure what it is
[Applause]
[Music]
just for if we've blurred out some of
the bodies here that's why you're not
seeing more but it's just a horrific
aftermath six victims killed instantly
two others died later on the way to the
hospital more than a dozen trying to
recover bill de blasio of course came
out and said this was an act of terror
and he said it was a particularly
cowardly act of terror aimed at innocent
civilians in to people going about their
lives who had no idea what was about to
hit them
here is some video of the suspect
actually who is it will actually been
played de Blasio here's what Blasio had
to say about it it's a very painful day
in our city horrible tragedy on the west
side let me be clear - based on the
information we have at this moment this
was an act of terror and a particularly
cowardly act of terror aimed at innocent
civilians aimed at people going about
their lives who had no idea of what was
about to hit them it was pretty clear
obviously immediately that this was an
Islamist an Islamist terror attack the
note was left in the car that made
reference to Isis the guy popped out of
the car the terrorists popped out of the
the truck and he was carrying I guess a
paintball gun the idea here is that he
was attempting to provoke death by cop
he wanted to make the police think that
he was going to shoot them and so he was
carrying around these guns obviously he
did not have more weapons on him which
is definitely a good thing there are
people like Nick Kristof yesterday
saying well that's because of gun
control in New York City well no it
really isn't if you were willing to get
in a car and run over people the idea
that you can't drive upstate grab some
guns drive back downstate and run around
New York City shooting people seems kind
of ridiculous and in case here's some
video of the suspect yesterday sprinted
toward the group of kid towards the
group of kids and about how long did
this take place how long were you
watching him for maybe 20 seconds before
I was just run back in just for my own
safety right and you say they looked
real but could you tell could you hear
if any
if any kind of mission we're coming out
of his gun or you didn't you couldn't
tell that I did not hear any thought and
I didn't the fire at anybody okay so he
didn't end up firing anybody because the
guns themselves were not real and again
he was attempting to provoke death by
cop here's a photo of the suspect and
here's what he looked like it looks like
a nice clean-cut Mormon boy obviously in
any case no this has obviously provoked
a bunch of media firestorm and it's
provoked some response from the
President of the United States I wanna
talk about the response from the media
and the response from the President of
the United States and I think that we
ought to be as as objective as we
possibly can in looking at these
responses objectively speaking the
response from the media is always quite
awful on all of this and I think that we
ought to start there here are some of
the headlines that you saw yesterday so
the you're gonna see a couple of
headlines one is from Fox News and the
other is from CNN and you'll see the
difference immediately the headline from
Fox News was at least six dead after
suspect crashes truck in lower Manhattan
shouts Allahu Akbar right allahu akbar
it means it means allah is great and and
then here was the headline from see it
from CNN fatalities reported after truck
rams people in manhattan again one of
those runaway trucks you know they just
go off on their own it's very very weird
how that happens right leaving out the
the whole allahu akbar routine instead
they just say that again a truck went
off on its own and committed these
egregious acts of terrorism we have to
be careful of our runaway truck
population because obviously those
trucks cannot be trusted anyone in a
Ford f-150 beware your truck may turn on
you and then CNN ran this Chiron in the
middle of this after the Allahu Akbar
information came out and said witnesses
suspect was yelling god is great in
Arabic well no the suspect was yelling
Allahu Akbar right and there is a
difference right saying god is great in
Arabic is is toning down a little bit
exactly what ahoo akbar is it is the
typical kind of thing that is screamed
by terrorists as they are in the midst
of terror attacks and there are a lot of
people who are who are obviously upset
about that particular chyron because the
idea here that god is great is the exact
equivalent to allahu akbar is is not
true considering that there is
significant I mean even even in the
Islamic community the idea that the God
that is worshipped by Islamic terrorists
is the same as the God
is worshipped in judeo-christian
societies that's a pretty dicey
proposition at best
and so CNN was getting a lot of flack
over this especially since everyone in
the Western world knows what occupier
means now and they know that it means
radical Islamic terrorists was just
running around killing people the the
equation of the jail Christian God with
the god of radical Islamic terror is is
quite egregious and quite disgusting so
you know this prompted some thoughts
from me yesterday about why it is that
the media treats this particular terror
attack Islamic terror attacks in a
different way than they treat for
example white supremacists
terror attacks so we saw a white
supremacist error aesthetic in the in
charlottesville when we saw a guy run a
truck exactly like this run a truck into
a civilian and kill a civilian in
Charlottesville we've also seen a white
supremacist terror attack in in landing
in South Carolina in in I'm gonna
remember the city Charlotte was a where
was it in South Carroll stone is in
Charleston South Carolina
Dylann storm roof murdering a bunch of
black folks who are simply attending
church because they were black and the
reaction from the media is completely
completely at odds so let's go through
this for just a second imagine for a
second that a white supremacist had
actually driven a truck onto a bike path
filled with minority innocence right he
went down to Harlem and he was running
down black folks in the middle of Harlem
killing eight of them and imagine the
white supremacists had emerged from his
truck wearing a confederate flag t-shirt
now imagine that the media had left left
to the defense of people flying the
Confederate flag explaining that only a
tiny minority of people who actually fly
the Confederate flag or like the
Confederate flag engaged in any sort of
racist violence which is true imagine
that all of America's political leaders
left to the microphones to say the same
thing Confederate flag does not mean
terrorists Confederate flag does not
mean white supremacists imagine that the
CNN at CNN ran a chyron reading not
witnesses suspect was yelling god is
great in Arabic but witnesses suspect
was carrying southern version of
American flag right which is what a lot
of people consider they the Confederate
flag to be and let's assume they then
hosted panels assuring audiences that a
Confederate flag was not a symbol of
racism or bigotry it was simply a symbol
of southern pride can you imagine the
media doing any of those things no of
course not because when a radical when a
white supremacist terror attack occurs
the media's immediate
fons is to jump to let's have a national
conversation about the Confederate flag
right a white supremacist terror attack
is obviously an offshoot it's obviously
is springing from a broader ideology
that can be traced to identity with the
Confederate flag right after the
Charlottesville terror attack we had a
month long discussion month long
discussion is still ongoing about
whether to remove Confederate statues as
though anyone who doesn't want to remove
Confederate statues is in league with
people who are running down innocents in
the middle of Charlottesville so
whenever it's a white supremacist who
does this we immediately link the white
supremacists with the ideology of
millions of other people have nothing to
do with the ideology and with symbols
that are used by millions of other
people in completely different ways when
it comes to radical Islam we don't do
that at all when it comes to radical
Islam instead we jump to something else
right we jump to defending Muslims from
any association with radical Islam I
know Jake Tapper with him I'm friendly
on CNN but Jake was was being criticized
last night and I think partly unfairly
but partly fairly he's being criticized
last night because he had said something
along the lines of Allahu Akbar was
yelled when this guy jumped out
sometimes said at kind of celebratory
occasions but now said on a terrible
occasion and people are saying well
would you say the same thing about the
Confederate flag like did you say the
Confederate flag is sometimes flown at
NASCAR stadiums but now being used as a
symbol of hate and I think that's not an
unfair critique I think people are
taking it out of context when they said
that that Tapper said Allahu Akbar it's
a beautiful phrase didn't actually say
that but the idea that he was trying to
provide context for Allahu Akbar and
people never in the media try to provide
context for for example the Confederate
flag or for Confederate statues it
demonstrates the the lack of honesty in
the media and it says something deeper
about the leftist point-of-view on
America and what America is
I'm explaining that in just a second but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipes delivery service in the country
years ago my wife said to me wouldn't be
awesome if there were some service where
instead of us going to the grocery store
and sort of estimating what we need to
cook tonight and then having to come up
with recipes they just sent you the
recipe and they sense everything
pre-bagged and they could just cook it
in your own home make a home-cooked meal
with the best ingredients and the recipe
well blue apron must have been reading
her mind because that's exactly what
they do
they've established partnerships
with over 150 local farms fisheries
ranchers across the United States and
they have made it possible for millions
of families to cook together to build
strong family bonds and blue apron
families cook nearly three times more
often than non blue apron families some
of their upcoming meals they they switch
out the recipes every single day pretty
much and they don't repeat recipes
inside a year unless you really like the
recipe so it's a lot of variety which is
great because in my house you know very
often we're eating the same meal like
every Tuesday like pretty much everyone
else blue apron makes that a thing of
the past customer favorites include
things like seared chicken and roasted
fall vegetables with caper butter pan
sauce Amina makes you into a gourmet a
gourmet cook 30-minute meals right sweet
pepper chicken with bok choy and rice
black bean and cheese tortas with
roasted broccoli and lime sour cream I
mean these are things that you'd get at
a restaurant in Sept you'd be paying
twice the price for food that isn't half
as good right now you get $30 off your
first order with free shipping by going
to blue aprons comm slash Shapiro again
that's blue apron comm slash Shapiro
you'll love how good it feels a taste to
create incredible home-cooked meals of
blue apron
do not wait blue apron comm slash
apparel half the people in the office
use blue apron blue apron comm slash up
hero blue apron is a better way to cook
okay so what exactly is driving this
disparity between how the media treat
Islamic terror attacks and how the media
treats supremacist terror attacks the
answer is the media believe that white
supremacist terror attacks are more
representative of America at large than
they believe that or at least southern
Americans or conservative Americans than
they believe that radical Islamic terror
attacks are representative of Muslims
across the world
this is effectually and statistically
it's just mistaken it's not true it's
just not true I mean the fact is there
are there are more people who have died
in white supremacist terror attacks
since 9/11 than have died in Islamic
terror attacks since 9/11 but that's
leaving out 9/11 number one and that
also leaves out the calculation of
politically motivated killings on the
other side meaning people from left who
are committing politically motivated
killings like you saw in the attempted
Congressional baseball shooting in any
case the idea that white supremacism is
more closely tied to conservative
ideology than radical Islam is tied to
Islam itself is bizarre and and
groundless and this is what the Left
believes right I mean this is why they
ran an ad two days ago excuse me in
Virginia the Latino victory fund ran an
ad two days ago in Virginia
showing a and Gillespie supporter flying
a confederate flag running down minority
children right we just saw yesterday
what actually is happening what actually
is happening is that a radical Muslim
just ran down a bunch of people in New
York at the ad that we saw from
Democrats was an ad in which Gillespie
supporter was running down a bunch of
minority children with the truck because
ed Gillespie supporters are in league
with the KKK and white supremacist
because they're conservative this is
this we have to be very careful about
attributing terrorist ideologies to
broader movement and we're gonna have to
be pretty careful about that across the
board we're gonna have to be as as
statistically accurate as possible
I cut a video several years ago in which
I talked about how representative is
terrorist ideology of broader Islamic
ideology and I used polls to sort of
suss out the idea that there are tens of
millions of Muslims who believe the same
things that a lot of the terrorists
believed okay that many more Muslims as
a percentage believe the Islamist
ideology then conservatives believe
white supremacist ideology and yet the
media treated as precisely the opposite
and that's why that also explains the
media's reaction to these attacks being
an immediate leap to we have to prevent
Islamophobia because remember the bad
guys in this scenario are not Muslims
right they're not Muslims and they're
not radical is radical Islamist may be
the bad guys but they're a tiny offshoot
right there they're just isolated
incidents that are lone wolves they
don't represent anything broader but
white supremacist do represent something
broader the evil cruel conservative
white America and those are the people
we constantly have to be on guard
against that's why the media are
constantly jumping to prevent
Islamophobia after there's an Islamic
terror attack even though no know
mosques are being burned down there have
been any riots in the streets people are
not going crazy and beating Muslims
about Muslims up on the streets the rate
of hate crimes against particular
religions remains far higher against
Jews than it is against Muslims as a
general matter across the United States
according to the FBI but we all have we
always have to worry about these hate
crimes we have to worry about
Islamophobia after a terror attack
because the bad guys that we have to
worry about are us we are the bad guys
this is the media's perspective on this
which is just wrong and immoral and the
disparity between the treatment of white
supremacists terror attacks and Islamist
terror attacks is quite telling and
shows you where the media's heads are at
now meanwhile President Trump and a lot
of the right have been immediately
jumping to policy prescriptions that
have to do with immigration because it
turns out that this guy
there's a green card holder from
Uzbekistan he came in under the
diversity visa program seven years ago
apparently there was no real sign that
he'd been radicalized there were some
conflicting reports there are some
people who are suggesting that the FBI
had had its eye on him in 2015 because
he had been hooking up with people who
are on the terror watch list that said
when he was originally checked he did
have to go through a screening program
and there were no red flags had nothing
but traffic tickets in the United States
there are some red flags as far as his
associates but that was late-breaking
right that was in the last two years
that was not in the first five years
that he was in the United States in fact
Governor Cuomo says that he was
radicalized while he was in the United
States who's not radicalized overseas
and then he was sort of an infiltrator
who came in through the diversity visa
program here's what President Trump
tweeted all right well President Trump
tweeted was that he said we must not
allow Isis to return or enter our
country after defeating them in the
Middle East and elsewhere enough and
then he tweeted also along those lines
in New York City looks like another
attack by a very sick and deranged
person law enforcement is following this
closely all caps not in the USA so there
are people making fun of not in the USA
obviously this is Trump making an appeal
for his immigration ban on particular
Muslim countries and here is what he
tweeted this morning he tweeted this
morning I have just ordered homeland
security to step up our already extreme
vetting program being politically
correct is fine but not for this and
then he said the terrorists came into
our country through what is called the
diversity Visa Lottery program a Chuck
Schumer beauty I want merit-based and
they said we are fighting hard for
merit-based immigration no more Democrat
lottery systems we must get much tougher
and smarter and then he was tweeting at
Fox & Friends the Senator Chuck Schumer
helping to import Europe's problem sent
Colonel Tony Shaffer we will stop this
craziness so the morning after the
terror attack Trump was live tweeting
Fox and Friends now it's the sentiment
here that I want to talk about for just
a second so I want to be both
intellectually honest and I think
factually honest about all of this a
couple things have to be pointed out
first of all I am against the diversity
visa program I think the diversity visa
program is stupid
I agree with President Trump that a
merit-based system on immigration is the
best system and the only system we
should be using we have the capacity as
a citizenry to pick the people who we
want to join our citizenry you do not
have a right to immigrate to the United
States just because you are from
Uzbekistan or just because you are from
the other country on planet Earth now we
get to pick and choose the people who
come into the country that said there
are some people on the Left who are
saying and Chuck Schumer is among them
saying you know Trump immediately
jumping to politicize this is bad faith
here is Chuck Schumer saying exactly
that after September 11th the first
thing the President Bush did was invite
senator Clinton and me to the White
House where he pledged to do what was
ever in his power to help our city
President Bush in a moment of national
tragedy understood the meaning of his
high office and sought to bring our
country together
president Trump where is your leadership
the contrast between President Bush's
actions after 9/11 and president Trump's
actions this morning could not be
stalker again mr. president president
Trump where is your leadership I'd say
in closing I have always believed that
immigration is good for America I
believe it today
president Trump instead of politicizing
and dividing America which he always
seems to do at times of national tragedy
should be bringing us together ok so we
can stop it there ok Chuck Schumer is a
giant hypocrite obviously because he was
politicized to every tragedy that he can
get his grubby mitts on I mean over and
over and over again right he's continued
to politicize tragedy repeatedly every
time there's a mass shooting for example
Schumer is the first to the mic so a
month ago after the Las Vegas rampage he
said as much as we might hope to we
cannot banish evil from the earth
Congress can't say that the president
can't do that what Congress can do what
Congress must do is pass laws to keep
our citizens safe and that starts with
guns especially laws that help prevent
guns especially the most dangerous guns
from falling into the wrong hands
Pelosi did the same thing Hillary
Clinton chimes in with regards to the
NRA
you know it was a bunch of people on the
right who scolded the left as al
opponent points out over at hot air for
leaping to half-baked policy fixes I was
one of those people right I said this is
not the time to talk about this for a
couple of reasons one I don't think that
in the aftermath
he's the best time to talk policy right
the reason being that passions are high
and passions don't necessarily make for
the best policy number two Las Vegas was
actually a unique situation we didn't
know what gun the guy had used we didn't
know how he obtained the gun we know
what his motivations were we didn't know
what fixes would actually have stopped
this thing in this particular case we
knew right away right within 24 hours
you know who the guy is we know why he
did it
we know how he got in the country and we
know how he obtained his weapon which
was a truck right we know all of those
things so it's easier to at least have
policy discussions on that basis but I
still think that it is bad policy it's
bad policy you forget that these sort of
optics of it I think it is bad policy to
talk about immigration reform in the
aftermath of this thing because it's
actually not factually supportable the
reason I say this is because when you
create a policy fix and again I agree
with Trump's policies right I agree that
Trump is correct on the diversity visa
program I've been in favor of a
merit-based program for years go watch
an interview that I did with Hannah
Coulter two years ago before Trump was
even running for office in which I
specifically talked about the visa
lottery program and all of this stuff
with an I totally agree that the the
idea that we have to have an affirmative
action program for particular countries
is quite foolish but if you think that
ending the diversity lottery program
would have stopped this guy from getting
in the country or that extreme betting
in the country that is not certain at
all especially because this happened in
2010 and if you're gonna blame Chuck
Schumer for it that doesn't work either
because as part of the gang of eight
bill that Chuck Schumer was trying to
push in 2013 it would have gotten rid of
the diversity visa program right what it
would have it would have gotten rid of
it so you know Chuck Schumer is is a
giant hypocrite but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the policy that's
being proposed by President Trump is a
fix is actually a fix and I'll talk a
little bit more about that again I agree
with Trump's policy but I think that we
should be careful when we propose a
policy that it actually fixes the thing
that we say that it's going to fix right
the reason that you don't want the
diversity visa program is not because we
think that it's going to lessen the risk
in any tremendous way of terrorists like
this one because the fact is this guy
could have come through France he could
have come through Britain I mean they're
Muslims who come through each of those
countries the the real issue here is the
cultural the the cultural melting pot
and whether people should come into the
country at all from particular countries
if they don't imbibe American culture
has a particular idea about immigration
that you should have a right to
immigrate there's sort of the basis for
all of these judicial decisions against
the Trump travel ban I think that's
nonsense but does that have much to do
with this terrorist attack not really
and I want to explain that in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at enzo Chino so you
know made-to-measure suits are gonna
make you look the best if you're a guy
and you want to look your best
then made-to-measure suits are the best
not grabbing something off the rack and
then having it sort of back tailored
instead making a suit from scratch you
know it's something that you thought
only James Bond was gonna be able to do
at some fancy at some fancy suit shop in
London now you get to do it too at endo
Chino really inexpensively they're
making it easy to get a perfectly
tailored suit at an incredible price you
can choose from hundreds of top quality
fabrics personalise your suit just the
way you want it whether it's for work a
wedding or another special occasion my
favorite suit is actually this kind of
light blue / grey suit that I got from
Indo Chino fits me great it's a
three-piece suit I went into their store
that measured it for me if they do it
wrong then you come back and they will
they'll redo it for you here's how it
works you visit a showroom or a shop
online at Enzo Chino com
you pick your fabric you choose your
customizations from lit from lapels to
pleats to jacket linings and more you
submit your measurements you place your
order and you wait for it to arrive in
just a few weeks and right now my
listeners ben shapiro listeners can get
Indo chinos best deal ever at 359 bucks
for any premium suit when you enter the
code Shapiro's during checkout again 359
bucks for any premium suit when you
enter the code Shapiro's during checkout
which is 50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure
premium suit shipping is free again Indo
Chino ind OCH ino enzo chino comm promo
code shapiro any premium suit 359 bucks
free shipping is great for weddings it's
great for special occasions and again
this is less than you will pay for an
off-the-rack suit at Macy's so go check
it out at ENSO Chino com promo code
Shapiro for your tailored suit it's it's
pretty awesome and again it's one of
those things where you don't have to
spend tons of money in order to feel
like you're extraordinarily wealthy
which is pretty cool okay so EDD
Morrissey has a very good piece over at
hot air talking about the manipulation
of the of the agenda in order to push a
particular political outcome so as I'd
mentioned says it's true that psy pop
gained entry to the United States
through the lottery process however psy
pop got here in 2010 long before the
refugee crisis began in Europe so in
right no one was talking about refugees
from the Middle East because that wasn't
a major issue yet he says furthermore
these refugees aren't coming from
Uzbekistan a country in Central Asia but
mainly from Syria and North Africa
mainly Libya right Trump has proposed
his travel ban on a set of countries
that does not include whose Becca Stan
news Becca Stan does have a terror
problem but extreme vetting probably
wouldn't stop this guy and who's Becca
Stan is not on Trump's travel ban list
which would suggest that if he actually
wants to stop the importation of people
who are potential terrorists or who do
not jive with American culture then we
ought to have more broad-based travel
restrictions more broad-based
immigration restrictions but again you
know what Trump is proposing here it's
sort of like when Democrats proposed
that we should have an assault weapons
ban after an assault weapon is not used
at a so-called assault weapon is not
used at a mass shooting writer they they
they ban some sort of unrelated policy
where we're gonna ban certain magazine
sizes that have nothing to do with the
efficacy of a mass shooting if you're
going to say that your policy solves a
problem it ought to solve the problem
and as Morrissey points out the lottery
program still requires the normal visa
application process from suspended visa
and foreign Refugee applications from
eight countries earlier this year but
who's becca stan was not on that list
and there's no evidence that site pol
was radicalized in Rebecca Stan then
waited seven years and decided to
conduct a truck attack that's not the mo
of a sleeper agent but more of a
recently radicalized impulse attacker
and then as far as Schumer and again I
want to be objective as possible and
bring out as many facts as possible here
the lottery system in question was part
of the Immigration Act of 1990 signed by
George HW Bush in 1990 20 years before
saibaba entered the u.s. that wasn't
introduced by by Chuck Schumer was
introduced by Ted Kennedy who's really
to blame for all of this Schumer didn't
join the Senate until 1999 again this is
a bipartisan move in 1990 to create this
diversity visa lottery program in fact
the diversity visa lottery program was
originally designed to make it easier
for European immigrants to get in
because the diversity the diversity visa
lottery program was designed to allow
countries that didn't have tons of
immigration right that had under I think
50,000 emigrants a year or 60,000
emigrants a year to the United States to
add people who are immigrating that was
designed for places like France places
like Italy I wasn't really designed for
whose Becca Stan and finally you know
statistically speaking the diversity
visa program admits about 50,000 people
year to the United States and has for
almost 30 years which means that more
than a million visas over that period of
time have been issued and saipa appears
to be the only person who's entered
through the diversity visa lottery
program who's committed a terror act so
the idea that this problem was caused by
the diversity visa lottery seems to me
wrong that said I'm against the
diversity Visa Lottery and this is why I
think that it's important to have these
policy discussions not in the aftermath
of terrorist attacks when everybody is
jazzed up because then we devolve into
this particular political battle one
side says we need to get rid of
diversity Visa Lottery in order to save
American lives and the other side says
this wouldn't have saved American lives
and the first side-side-side says you
don't care enough about saving American
lives and then the second side says well
you don't care enough about immigrants
that seems to me the same reverse of
what we do on gun control after a mass
shooting alright people on the right say
that's not good policy and it's not
gonna help and the left says you don't
care enough about the people who are
shot I don't like this argument on
either side again there is a strong case
for the fifth time there's a strong case
that everything Trump is saying about
immigration is true in a generalized
sense but suggesting that this would
solve the terrorists problem is I think
setting up an expectation that is not
accurate you know the sort of fortress
America mentality with regard to with
regard to protecting the United States
there's some truth to it but I don't
think there's a complete truth to it and
again when you're talking about
radicalization of people who are already
in the United States it seems to me that
the best way that you can actually fight
this is by crushing Isis overseas and
destroying the the motivation for people
to become terrorists see I think this is
really the biggest problem we're
constantly looking for ending the means
when we're not looking for stopping bad
people from becoming bad people we're
looking for ending the means I'm not
sure that that is necessarily going to
to work so we can kill as many
terrorists as possible over there and we
should do that we should prevent as many
terrorists as possible ferment for
entering the country that's why I should
have a vetting program and a lot of
these visa programs you know just on a
cultural level but what's really going
to stop terrorists the reason terrorists
commit terrorist attacks people think
they do it out of despair right this is
a lefty trope that the reason the
terrorists commit terrorist attacks is
out of despair I don't think the
terrorists commit terrorist attacks out
of despair
I think terrorists commit terrorist
attacks out of hope they think they're
going to win they think they're gonna go
to heaven they think their side is going
to be for
these committed them committing these
atrocities apparently this human piece
of debris was in the hospital last night
bragging about what he'd done and
talking about how wonderful all of it
was right and talking about how it was
it was just great because he's a
disgusting human being well the the
reason that you didn't have this level
of terror attack
you know before Isis's rise is because
there was no hope that Isis was going to
win crushing Isis overseas demonstrating
that the might of Islamic terrorism
doesn't win you battles it gets you
killed that seems to me the best way to
defeat this particular scourge now is
that going to end all terror attacks no
it's not gonna end all terror attacks
and we should be taking defensive
measures I mean one of the obvious ones
is and I don't know why they don't have
this they should have bike paths that
are basically restricted by these cement
medians right Israel has that and has
had it for a long time it prevents these
trucks from driving into areas where
people are running that seems to me like
a relatively smart thing to do you can
put it on sidewalks as well I know there
are parts of New York City like Times
Square actually has these that seems to
me like that's something that might be
worthwhile but again I just want to
recommend that we look at this in the
cold light of day if we're going to make
a decision about the diversity visa
lottery program it shouldn't be on the
back of this terror attack which again
is an isolated incident specifically
with regard to that program we should
look at it and say is this good policy
or is a bad policy I think it's bad
policy I think it should go but if we're
gonna talk about extreme betting is that
good policy or bad policy it's good
policy I think that we should do it I
can agree with all of Trump's policies
without suggesting that this terrorist
act be a leverage point for those
policies Trump can win that battle on
the merits without getting into the the
nasty business of trying to suggest that
a particular terror attack could have
been prevented by this specific policy
fix which I really don't think is
accurate okay well we're gonna continue
and talk about this we're also going to
do some things I like and some things I
hate and some Bible talk but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire comm and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you can subscribe to daily wire
comm this will allow you to watch the
rest of our show on video live they'll
allow you to watch the rest of the
Michael Noel's show live it'll allow you
to watch the rest of the Andrew Clavin
show live plus it means that you can get
the website without that banner ad on it
which is pretty cool mr. Perot store is
launching in the next couple of months
you'll get discounts there if you
remember plus if you're an annual
member then you for $99 here you get all
of those things plus this leftist here
is a hot or cold tumbler which is the
epitome of Awesomeness it's just
something that you will enjoy every
single day and you will love it it's
it's a prized possession in every
household that owns one I mean it goes
right in the safe and very few people
use it but when you do you just feel the
glory flowing through you in any case
that that's that's what you get for the
the month for the annual subscription or
if you want to subscribe later go to
iTunes or SoundCloud please join us on
our YouTube channel subscribe over there
we have plenty of new content coming out
over there that's pretty awesome we had
a lot of Halloween content yesterday you
can check out at our YouTube channel oh
if you just again want to listen later
leave us a review at any of the places
you listen to the show we always
appreciate it we are the largest and
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]
now with all of that said about why I
think it's a mistake to use this terror
attack as a leverage point for
immigration I think it is also important
to note that because Trump does talk
about things like culture because he
does talk about things like immigration
generally this is why he is popular and
the Democrats are falling into a trap if
they decide to fight him on this the
Democrats think that they're gonna win a
battle every time there's a mass
shooting and they talk about gun control
they think they've won a public
relations battle Trump thinks he's gonna
win an immigration battle on this score
he's probably right on a political level
it's not stupid what Trump is doing I
think that what Trump is doing on a
political level is actually you know
politically advantageous for him and for
his agenda I just don't like it as a
general matter but that's not the same
thing as saying that what he's doing is
stupid I don't think that it's stupid
you know Trump is is is sort of
reference level gut response to all of
this stuff and I think that that is and
I think that that's why he's popular
right he's popular because people feel
like it's only political it's only
political correctness that prevents
people from speaking about the cultural
problems inherent in all of us right
there's there some of the unites the two
conversations we've had today the
conversation about radical Islam and its
relationship to normal Islam and the and
the conversation about immigration and
that is these are topics that people are
afraid to talk about because they are
afraid that they are going to be
undercut by the general media atmosphere
and this is why Trump won right there's
a poll out yesterday that from from Cato
Institute and what that poll basically
showed is that a huge percentage of
Americans hate political correctness and
find it to be stifling in fact I think
it's seventy one percent of Americans
say that they hate political correctness
and feel that they can't actually speak
out on issues of serious concern you
know the that that same percentage of
people basically feel like they have to
silence themselves on all of this and I
think the debt exactly is that is the
reason why Trump won the reason why
Trump won the reason why Trump is gonna
continue to be popular is because
instead of the left responding as I have
and saying listen you know the policy
prescriptions that you're talking about
we can have a good debate about that but
I don't think that this is either the
time or the matter upon which to use
that rhetoric which is what I said about
gun control instead they've decided to
say we can never discuss this the only
reason you to discuss this is because
you're Islamophobic the only reason you
discuss this is because you hate Muslims
okay the response to that is what drove
Trump that Cato Institute poll shows in
living color white Trump 171 percent of
Americans according to the poll believe
that political correctness has done more
to silence important discussions our
society needs to have that's why Trump
explicitly referenced political
correctness in his series of tweets only
28% of Americans think political
correctness has bettered Society and
that shows why the left is losing 73
percent of Americans of Republicans
rather say that they are more likely to
keep their views to themselves
fifty-eight percent of independents say
the same thing they feel silenced Trump
gives them a voice so even when Trump is
using his voice in ways that I don't
particularly think are appropriate he's
still doing something the left refuses
to do because the left doesn't see any
time when we should have this discussion
I'm happy to have a gun control
discussion any time the left wants to
except right after a national tragedy
when they're exploiting that for
political gain I think we should have
those discussions but what I really
object to is I've said I said it during
the gun control debate and I'm saying it
now I don't like the association between
tragedy and policy I think it makes for
bad policy right I think the Department
of Homeland Security which is a bad
policy decision was formed in the
aftermath of 9/11 and has done very
little to keep the country safer I think
that if we had had one less agency one
less department we would just be if it
had been part of the Department of
Defense for example we'd have been just
as safe there are a lot of bad policy
decisions that are made on the basis of
emotional response to bad things
happening I just don't like that as a
general matter but Trump is willing to
talk about these things and he's
constantly willing to talk about these
things and it's the left's willingness
to shut down the debate that is driving
support for President Trump right this
is this is why I think this poll is sort
of telling okay time for some quick
things I like some things I hate and
then we'll do a little bit of Bible talk
so things that I like today so we've
been doing baby books healing books you
should read as a young parent there's
there's a good book called brain rules
for baby by a guy named John Medina how
to raise a smart and happy child from 0
to 5 and John Medina talks about sort of
all of the topics that you would that
you would think you need to know about
like should you allow your kid to watch
TV how you handle temper tantrums this
is how do you teach them impulse control
the best the best predictors of academic
performance
you know all of these things are in the
book it's a really good way of looking
at how to parent your child and I highly
recommend it again the book is brain
rules for baby by John Medina well worth
reading okay other things that I like so
Bernie Sanders shockingly said something
that I liked yesterday so a lot of
people over the last couple of days have
been spending an awful lot of time and
effort particularly the media talking
about Russian collusion right it's the
collusion we have to talk about whether
Trump was colluding with Russia Bernie
Sanders has a better handle on what
Americans want to hear about than most
of the Democratic Party which is why if
Bernie actually runs in 2020 he will
present a serious threats about the
Democratic Party and to President Trump
in his reelection effort I'm serious
about that Bernie is a crazy old man
he's a loon bag loves pudding you know
all of that's true but Bernie Sanders
has a better handle on what the American
people care about than most of the
mainstream media look how upset Seth
Meyers is asking Bernie Sanders about
the rush of stuff in hand and having
Bernie basically shoot it down I mean I
think we've got to work in two ways
number one we have got to take on
Trump's attacks against the environment
against women against Latinos in black
sand and people in the gay community
we've got to fight back every day on
those issues but equally important or
more important we have got to focus on
the bread-and-butter issues that means
so much to ordinary Americans Americans
are not staying up every day worrying
about Russians Russia's interference in
our elections they're wondering how
they're gonna be able to send their kids
to college they're worried about how
they're gonna be able to pay the rent
they're worrying about whether they can
afford health care they're worried about
whether their income they make is enough
to put food on the table okay so you
know I think that this is at the
beginning of what he's saying of course
is stupid but the very end when he says
that people aren't that concerned about
Russia he's correct about this and this
is why he is more likely to to resonate
with more Americans than the Democratic
Party which is constantly focused on
Russia mostly because they are focused
on mostly because they want to justify
why Hillary Clinton could possibly have
lost this election okay and other things
that I like this is just breaking now
and I think this is pretty spectacular
Trump is trying to create a
named for the tax cut act that he's
trying to pass this is the scoop you
ready for this is amazing
Trump wants to name the tax bill I kid
you not the cut cut cut act that's
really what he wants to call it the cut
cut cut act
apparently House Hill leaders disagree
now listen I think that the cut cut cut
act I mean frankly it sounds more like a
bris Milla attends more like a
circumcision ceremony than it does like
a tax cut thing but if somebody was
suggesting the tax cut him it cut face
act of 2017 I think that's pretty
spectacular
listen Trump has a better idea for
branding than the than the Republican
Party I mean they'll call it something
like the revitalize the economy in a
great way act right then it'll be some
sort of crazy acronym that'll end up
being you know revitalize but every one
of those letters will have its own will
have its own word it'll be the
revitalize the economy in virulent and
I'm not gonna do the entire word of
revitalize it's too long in the Lord but
that's what they would do so I sort of
liked the cut cut cut act although I do
think it does sound like a rabid
director trying desperately to prevents
a scene from going off the rails to cut
cut cut act so a well done president
Trump okay time for some things that I
hate we talked about this a little bit
yesterday apparently John Kelly's a
racist so the left has had enough of
John Kelly the reason they've had enough
of John Kelly is because John Kelly
actually came out and defended President
Trump they're fine with Kelly when he
just looked very exercised and
disappointed in President Trump at
Charlottesville but when he's actually
out there defending Trump's agenda then
they're very angry at Kelly so Kelly
said a couple of things in an interview
with Laura Ingraham that were
controversial first he said that the
Civil War was fought because there was
lack of compromise and he said that
there are a lot of people on the
southern side who were honorable people
and second he said some things about
China now what's amazing to me is that
the stuff he said about China for me is
way worse than the stuff he said about
the Civil War what he said about China
is that China seems to be a regime that
represents what its people want which is
just insane I mean it's a communist
regime that represses and oppresses its
people but the thing that the left jumps
on the Left agrees with that the left
likes China so instead the Left jumped
on the civil war stuff so now you've got
CNN's Chris Cuomo basically saying that
you know Kelly ignored and rationalized
bigotry by saying that the Civil War
wasn't about slavery
Kelly who isn't respected died how he
leads men and women how he has organized
his attention to duty that's all true
I've checked it ten ways from Sunday
it's true but giving him credit for a
political modulating ethos Asst is false
it's always been false the idea that he
would control the president's political
instantly division was always an empty
promise and this is the proof listen to
what he's saying and listen to where
we've heard it before you've heard it
come out of the president's mouth
it's crisis of conscience think about
the monuments in a different way maybe
then these people want to take them down
it's bigotry being ignored and
rationalized and Kelly is not gonna make
it better he's making it the same or
worse the attacks on Kelly of course are
now growing in size and scope because
they the Democrats know and the media
know that Kelly is an effective
spokesperson for sort of trumpian
philosophy it is insane to suggest that
Kelly is a racist because he said the
lack of ability to compromise led to the
civil war first of all he didn't even
sound which side right he it was the
South's refusal to compromise that led
to the civil war there are multiple
attempts to compromise there was the
Missouri Compromise there was an attempt
there's the Fugitive Slave Act right
there they're a bunch of attempts to
compromise on the part of Congress all
of which would be compromised with the
incredible evil of slavery and I will
say that in historical context I think
that it's important to note that you
know that there's this sort of binary
view that has now prevailed among people
of today because we all know slavery is
evil there's sort of this binary view
that says that anyone who wants it to
try and compromise with the South wanted
to uphold slavery that's not true there
are a lot of people who wanted to try
and create compromise with the South
hoping that slavery would eventually die
out the real reason the civil war
happened is because the United States
was expanding to the west and there were
serious concerns about whether slavery
was going to expand into the western
states the civil war in the end turned
out to be about abolishing slavery south
of the mason-dixon line as well but
originally remember the Civil War was
not about abolishing slavery in South
Carolina was really about abolishing
slavery in places like Kansas and
Nebraska right in the John Brown was
fighting wars out in Kansas to try and
stop slavery from from entry
in Kansas so I think there's a little
more complexity to the Civil War than
boiling it down to simply pro-slavery
anti-slavery although that is a good
shorthand I don't think that's the
entirety of their of the matters to
discuss in the Civil War
you know states rights versus national
prerogatives it was definitely on the
table you know the to pretend that
wasn't on the table is to be ignorant
even if the states rights were being
used in defense of something evil like
slavery okay time for a little bit of
Bible talk since it is Wednesday so I've
sort of been picking and choosing from
the biblical canon to talk about so last
week I did sort of the creation of the
universe and the the Adam and Eve story
today I'm into the Cain and Abel story
so I thought this was perfectly
appropriate for Halloween so believe it
or not the Cain and Abel story is about
cultural appropriation yes really it's
about cultural appropriation so why is
that if you look back in the Bible what
happens in the Cain and Abel story is
that both Cain and Abel decide that they
are going to commit sacrifices to God
right they want to sacrifice to God and
so Abel chooses from the fat of his
flock and Cain chooses from just he just
chooses some vegetables and it doesn't
sage has the best ones he was a farmer
and so he just chose whatever was what
he was sort of left over and he
sacrificed his God accepts Abel's
sacrifice but he doesn't accept Cain's
sacrifice now Cain has a choice Cain can
either look at that and say what can I
learn from Abel what's it a balloon
right that I did wrong how do I fix this
or he can get angry that Abel's
sacrifice was accepted in his was not he
can justify to himself that God is
unfair that the universe is unfair and
it can anger him so much that he ends up
killing Abel because how dare Abel holds
a different standard the reason this is
cultural appropriation is because the
whole idea behind most cultural
appropriation is not about mocking the
culture that you are attempting to
appropriate is about looking at the cool
things that other cultures do and saying
this is a good thing and I want to
imitate it imitation is how society gets
better it's how your child learns when
you have a three-year-old the way that
your three-year-old your two-year-old
learns is by imitating your behavior
that's why you have to model good
behavior we as adults should be doing
the same thing and so the idea that
cultural appropriation is a great evil
because I like you know I hear your girl
and you like hoop earrings and you think
they're cool and pretty and so you wear
them and this is some sort of insult no
what would you rather that the person
hate hoop earrings because they're
beautiful but they can't have them it's
really stupidity so the idea of
appropriating
things that other people do that's how
civilizations get better that's how
civilizations grow but destroy
civilizations is the refusal to
acknowledge that somebody did something
in way that was better than your way and
instead you get angry and you attempt to
destroy that way and and that's really
what the Cain and Abel story is about
it's about Halloween costumes no I'm not
really bit but kind of in any case we'll
be back here tomorrow with much much
more and we'll bring you the latest
updates on this horrific terror attack
in New York City I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]